hi in this video I'm going to be
covering the second mode that I use in
Indian clubs my previous video covered
the first mode which was same time same
direction if you haven't already seen it
I'll post a link in the description
below so if you go watch that and then
come back to
this in this video I'm going to be
covering same time opposite direction
which is the second mode demonstrating
the movements here without clubs just
like in mode one you need to be aware of
the four key
points
so as you can see here the left and
right hand are mirroring each other um
and I'm also alternating which hand goes
on top so it'll be right on the left and
left on the
right so like with all modes there's two
directions so with the previous one I
was going inwards with this one I'm
going
outwards you can see here I'm also
paying attention to the key points left
and right and the bottom and
top so once you've got that just smooth
[Music]
out okay one of the mistakes to look at
is where people raise their shoulders
like this what you want to do is drop
your shoulders back to a nice
comfortable relaxed position and just
maintain that structure
throughout okay then let's have a look
with clubs so obviously both arms can't
exactly mirror cuz otherwise the club
will Clash like
this so to get around this if you shift
one side of your body backwards and the
other forwards this enables the clubs to
pass each other here you can see I'm
exaggerating the movement once you
comfortable with you can reduce the
amount the
shift so same for swinging outwards this
time instead of crossing the clubs at
the top you want to be Crossing them at
the bottom and following the same
principles of Shifting forward and the
other back
ones
so to demonstrate the movement here's an
inward
swing and also swinging
outs so here we'll have a look at double
Inward and outward
Mills using the understanding of reals
from the first mode if you can see here
I'm doing a Rael if you just take one
hand and do a real
and then try straighten up your body and
rather than turning do the same movement
of the re just opening up your
chest and moving from your
elbow so if you're try and get the key
points as well so mooving to the right
then to the top of the head and then
round the front back down and then try
and smooth the movement out
so here I'm mirroring the movement with
my left hand trying to hit those key
points once I've done that I want to try
and smooth the movement
out okay so once you're happy with that
both sides uh you then just mirror the
movement and remember the same idea
about Crossing that arms at the top and
you're going inwards
[Music]
remember to alternate
the so now with my right hand I'm going
outwards doing the full turn as if I was
doing a
real and then I'm starting to straighten
up my body just moving from the
elbow the
shoulder try and do it in walk motion
so here I'm doing it with the left
hand going
outwards turning from the body to begin
with and then I'll straighten
up just try and do it from the elbow and
shoulder so just like going inwards you
want to be hitting those key points as
you're going
outwards opening up your chest and
mirroring your
movement there's a transition point in
front of your face that looks like a big
mustache that's a point that you want to
reach before you take the clubs behind
your
head once you're happy with that
movement just smooth it
out okay that's it for this video the
next mode will be covering split time
opposite direction thanks for
watching